bonsoir ravi de vous retrouver au café
picouly
pour ce dernier rendez vous de l'année
et oui déjà mais voyons tout de suite le
sommaire à la question d'échec et mat ce
soir sera comment faire aimer la
littérature pour y répondre
charles dantzig et son déjà fameux
dictionnaire égoïste de la littérature
face à lui jean joseph julaud pour la
littérature française pour les nuls
didier van cauwelaert nous donnera son
cours de littérature à propos de marcel
aymé notre inattendu sera nan aurousseau
pour son roman bleu de chauffe à bernard
werber dans tout le monde répondra à une
critique assez salée à propos de son
dernier roman le souffle des dieux de
hubert artus dans l'écho des savanes
patrick pelous le médecin urgentiste
nous donnera sa lecture de voyage au
bout de la nuit de louis ferdinand
céline
l'auteur américain le grand auteur
américain brett easton et nissa nous
livrera son journal intime
enfin je donnerai un petit coup pouce à
des ouvrages que j'ai particulièrement
aimé dernièrement ce soir ce sera une
sorte de trio amoureux il y aura les
honneurs à delphine et robert maintenant
que vous connaissez le sommaire entre
ont tout de suite à l'intérieur pour
notre première rencontre
[Musique]
e
notre séquence échec et mat alors notre
question ce soir
comment faire aimer la littérature
messieurs vous êtes là pour ça vous êtes
là pour nous faire aimer la littérature
alors d'un côté charles dantzig 43 ans
poète écrivain éditeur notamment
responsable des cahiers rouges chez
grasset et vous publiez ce dictionnaire
égoïste de la littérature française qui
est un des succès la rentrée on peut le
dire mille pages de parti-pris égoïste à
vous dites ce que vous pensez comme vous
le souhaitez et je crois qu'on vous a
trouvé très culottée dans la presse en
face de vous jean joseph julaud 54 ans
vous avez été enseignant jusqu'en 2004
je vais regarder un oui alors j'ai pas
dire de bêtises mais ils ont au collège
de guéméné penfao est ce que ça suppose
que c'est une espèce de le culbute de
syllabes avec des voyelles et s'amusent
toujours voile alors c'est en
loire-atlantique et vous êtes avant
hauteur dans la même collection de
l'histoire de france pour les nuls qui
s'est vendu à 300 mille exemplaires il
ya un énorme succès et ce soir vous êtes
là pour la littérature française pour
les nuls
paru chez first editions donc vous
connaissez le principe de l'émission
vous êtes devant une pendulette qui va
vous permettre d'interrompre votre
interlocuteur vous parlez vous répondez
aux questions et cette pendule est à
vous arbitrez normalement chronométrés
votre temps de façon à ce qu'on soit
équitable alors la première question que
je vais me permettre de vous poser est
ce que vous ne croyez pas s'il ya
abondance d'ouvragés sur la littérature
et je vais vous poser la question à vous
est-ce que c'est pas parce que justement
la littérature est malade et qu'on fait
des livres parce qu'on ne lit plus c'est
le
la lecture effectivement être un loisir
qu'on pratique de moins en moins parce
que peut-être on n'a pas su
inciter à la pratique et que d'autres
activités ont pris la place de la
lecture
il y a par exemple toute activité liée à
l'ordinateur etc qui se sont implantés
il faut pas oublier que quand on parle
de littérature on sort on parle d'une
frange de la population qui est quand
même très réduite il ya 12 % de gens qui
achètent des livres il y en a 7 % qui
les lisent et dans 5 % qui achètent des
îles peut-être pour changer j'appelle
jury bah c'est à dire je suis pas
d'accord avec un terme c'est que de dire
que la lecture est un loisir c'est
quelque chose de plus important est de
plus de plus grave
alors concrètement ce qui s'appelle se
parler librement ses proust auteurs
austro-hongrois écrivent en français
jules romains c'est la sofres le seul
genre là c'est à dire la sofres ça veut
dire qu'il met des pourcentages de
personnes oui pas seulement ça simmons
est l'auteur le plus comique stendhal
il est partial de mauvaise foi et
souvent il fait le malin et ainsi de
suite
yourcenar cela viau labrador enveloppé
dans un torchon
moi j'aime bien les laboratoires non et
au sénat c'est mieux qu'un labrador
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas un petit peu
jaloux de cette liberté de ton qui peut
prendre puisqu'il va s'occuper des morts
est là j'aurais bien aimé faire faire un
livre de ce genre là mais ça n'était pas
mon cahier des charges
j'écris pour une collection il y aura un
jules ou des morts bon jeu
des morts peut-être ça me divertir est
beaucoup voilà quand on a une c'est
cette liberté totale bien c'est
certainement un extrême plaisir quoi que
j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir à écrire
on apprend à le dire parce que j'ai
ajouté mon propre cahier des charges
j'ai voulu que dans chaque paragraphe il
y ait un sourire une émotion une
information aussi des anecdotes parce
que l'idée de donner les anecdotes mais
parce que les anecdotes c'est important
ça rend la littérature humaine ou
comprenez quand vous lis quand quand on
apprend que racine avait sous l'oeil
d'une cicatrice parce qu'à l'âge de huit
ans il s'était battu avec ses
condisciples au collège de beauvais ça
évidemment ça n'apporterait à la
compression littéraire de racines mais
ça montre que c'est un homme vivant et
c'était pas une statue à vénérer c'est
un être humain et que corneille lui dans
le plancher de son appartement rue de
cléry avait taillé une trappe qu'il
soulevait pour s'adresser à son frère
qui était au rez de chaussée et pour lui
demander une rime quand il n'en trouvait
pas moi je trouve cette genre de détails
vous avez raison on utilise un petit peu
le même procédé
c'est délicieux quand même de lire ces
petites choses la grande bourgeoise où
les jeunes est ce que vous pensez pas
que le livre de charles dantzig
s'adresse aux écrivains je trouve qu'il
ya une partie importante sur jeu si les
lan accueillir moi j'aime bien votre
livre parce que j'y prends du plaisir
depuis que
achetez des spas et je trouve que en
fait on sert la même cause moi j'attends
les lecteurs à l'entrée de la
littérature et vous attendez à la sortie
en fait ils sont coincés
j'ai grand plaisir à entendre des gens
simples qui disent j'ai lu le dernier
marc levy il m'a plu davantage ou moins
que le précédent mais en fait ce sont
des gens qui ne lirai rien d'autre et
voyez des gens simples et vous dites des
gens qui ne disait rien donc pourquoi
vous partez de ce préjugé les gens
peuvent très bien lire proust ça n'est
pas compliqué ça n'est pas compliqué ce
qui est compliqué ce n'est pas compliqué
tout ce qui est compliqué ce que c'était
mal écrit on peut on a du mal à lire
leaké mal écrit prou ce n'est pas mal
écrit c'est passionnant ya aucune raison
qu'ils ont raison de se dire que des
gens simples ne m'aurait pas lire ça
allait je n'ai pas dit simple api
condescendance et mépris
non non non non je n'en sais pas ça
c'est parce que je voulais dire qu' il y
avait des gens qui n'avaient jamais lu
parce que ils n'ont pas forcément eu un
cursus scolaire qui les a conduits vers
la lecture et que peut-être sur le tard
ils s'y sont mis grâce à des écrivains
prises et lé grenelle rivenq avions
tellement cursus pour lire il ya des tas
de gens qui lisent et qui en bavent 25
vous et moi vous devez recevoir des
lettres de lecteurs qui n'ont pas de
diplôme
je vais vous demander que l'état les
lumières tous les deux là vous êtes des
idées en tout cas des élèves
indisciplinés
jean joseph julaud c'est vous qui avez
la lumière c'est vous qui avez la parole
alors qu'est ce que je vais dire la rue
de là puisque aimant mais je suis
vraiment persuadé de ça il ya aucune
raison de penser que certains auteurs
sont compliquées et access est
accessible à certains types de genre les
gens que vous appelez simples sont tout
à fait capables de lire racines proust
et des choses comme ça seulement il va
encore faut-il les y conduit mais non
parce qu'ils ont une idée intimider des
choses on leur dit proust et c'est un
mot qui clique est comme ça qu'ils
intimident parce qu'ils se disent c'est
compliqué c'était c'est pas pour moi ça
n'est pas vrai c'est une la littérature
est une chose très simple
n'importe qui peut prendre proust
évidemment il faut prendre un peu de
temps pour le lire parce que ça fait
3000 pages mais ça n'est pas compliqué
c'est à la portée de tout le monde c'est
évident avec ça
un certain réalisme il faut quand même
une initiation il faut quand même une
motivation
il faut qu'il y ait un peu une
connaissance des auteurs pour qu'on
puisse aller vers eux vous n'allez pas
quand même imaginer quelqu'un qui se
rueraient dans une algérie et guy
commencer comment j'ai fait moi quand
j'étais petit je volais des livres dans
la ville exception je ne peux dire que
j'ai lu proust pour une très très
mauvaise raison qu'ils étaient qu au
lieu d'acheter une maquette d'avion un
jour j'ai acheté prise parce que j'avais
une petite fille qui a acheté procès je
trouvais ça anormal qu'elle le lise
et j'ai lu tout prouvé pas raison de
dire non mais c'est une très bonne
raison et ça montre encore une 7h15
il montre qu'il n'y a pas de prêt
déterminisme sur les lectures l'espère
bon alors moi je vais maintenant vous
vous donnez un sujet les femmes je vous
trouve charles dantzig que les auteurs
femmes sont très mal traités dans vos tv
ce qu'ils aient conscience de ça non pas
du tout c'est une chose qu'on m'a
reproché à cause d'eux à cause de
colette en particulier mais ça n'est pas
vrai si vous prenez ce que je dis de
madame de staël dont je dis que c'est
l'un des meilleurs écrivains la
littérature française ce que je dis de
louise labé
ce que je dis de beaucoup d'autres et
d'ailleurs cela semble la plus grande
preuve que je ne suis pas misogyne comme
un critique l'a dit c'est que j'étais
sélectionnée dans le prix femina
yourcenar mais on a le droit de ne pas
aimer dieu sur rien a redonné mois et
d'ailleurs quand je le dis du mal de
yourcenar et de colette colette est une
femme qui a laissé mourir ça m'inquiète
qui était quand même d'une férocité sans
nom et dans la morale oui c'est normal
on me reproche une chose moral donc je
réponds comme et yourcenar qui était pas
d'une gentillesse sans nom dont une qui
elle même dansé la façon dont elle
traite ses personnages dans ses livres
et très méprisant mannheim lafayette cet
art où croyez qu'elle avait craché dans
mais madame de lafayette c'est juste
c'est un peu comme ça de la broderie de
dame qui s'occupe le oui mais je dis
aussi des choses affreuses sur des
hommes jean joseph julaud vous dites
aurions alors façade et j'écoute je suis
je vous écoute et puis je ne sais pas
quoi dire
vous étiez bien pour vous dire savoir
yourcenar c'est quelqu'un qui admire
beaucoup
dont j'admire le style et je ne
comprends pas très bien qu'on lui en
veuille d'avoir à ce point réussi à
manier la langue française en lui
donnant une espèce de noblesse dans le
style et des deux côtés et
esthétiquement parfait
non c'est pas parfait c'est un peu
scolaire yourcenar ses romans sont pas
très bons en câlinant ce qui est très
bien à yourcenar ce sont ses mémoires
les mémoires de guerre sonars sont très
bons les romans soit on peut appliquer
quand même sinon historique à ben non je
trouve
je trouve que ce côté péremptoire mais
il était retourné oui c'est ça alors ça
manque un peu de souplesse tout ça mais
joseph donc puisque je dis que puisque
jeudi que les mémoires sont des livres
sans des bons livres c'est au contraire
du g20 n'est pas obligé de monde dans
mon blog un écrivain voix l'abbé georges
les us que vous par contre on a
l'impression que vous aimez tout le
monde parce que c'est pas long je devais
tout le monde mais j'ai envie de faire
aimer tout le monde rit et je sais très
bien mais tout juste nommé au delà d'une
vision un petit peu idéalisée que vous
avez du contact entre les lecteurs et la
littérature ça c'est une espèce de
théorie mais il ya la pratique et puis
il ya le terrain et là ça se passe pas
tout à fait comme ça bâle la partie que
jamais les gens achètent le livre donc
vote avait fait ça serve aussi une
pratique celle observée au delà d'une
observation marchande
il faut quand même rang au revoir donc
au delà il faut quand même aussi voir la
réalité sur le long terme sur le long
terme on sera morts le long terme de
notre vie il faut il faut quand même moi
je veux apporter quelque chose aux
lecteurs je vais leur faciliter la tâche
et puis je aller ils sont à l'oeuvre sur
pas leur faim on peut aussi c'est
précisément le fait qu'on exprime des
avis et qui ne sont pas universellement
bon et sucrée que les gens trouvent
comprennent qu'il ya un goût et koné
projets de chacun peut avoir réussir je
fais confiance à l'intelligence du
lecteur je n'ai pas besoin de vous dire
ce qu'il doit penser d'une oeuvre
il est capable de le faire il est assez
grand je ne juge pas et ils vont
connaître l'auteur ils vont aller vers
les livres et ils se feront leur opinion
tout seul je voudrais quand sur un plan
positif que vous disiez chacun là après
l'autre jean-joseph s'il voulait
commencer
qu'est ce serait le livre le livre que
vous conseilleriez à quelqu'un qui se
serait peut-être un peu éloigné de la
littérature et que vous aimeriez
admettons tiens je dire fred vargas pars
vite et reviens tard c'est un excellent
livre ça c'était pas tant moi j'ai fait
j'ai passé quelques heures de bonheur à
lire un maître du roman policier
français et c'est cet unique cette eau
est celui d'une amie
c'est un excellent petit tour dans la
littérature parce qu elle écrit très
très bien et puis se remettre c'est
quelqu'un qui aurait vous dit peut-être
besoin de se remettre en jambes avec
nous et je pense que c'est un une très
bonne médiation genre eh bien moi je
dirais un écrivain qui est un roman que
je pense vous aimez beaucoup daniel que
le fermina marquez de valery larbaud qui
est un grand écrivain et ça montre qu'un
grand écrivain peut écrire des grands
romans qui sont pas plus compliqué à
lire que roman supposé simple c'est une
histoire très très brève en 150 pages
d'un groupe de collégiens avant la
guerre de 14 dans un petit collège aux
environs de paris qui sont émerveillés
par l'arrivée de jeunes filles sud
américaines dans leur collège et c'est
un bijou un chef-d'oeuvre de style et à
une histoire merveilleuse voilà écrit
l'ars beauvoir fermin a marqué le voilà
écoutez monsieur je vous remercie en
tout cas ce que je peux dire à tout un
chacun sait que au terme de ce débat
j'espère qu'on vous aura donné envie en
tout cas de lire la littérature
française pour les nuls de jean joseph
julaud et charles dantzig dictionnaire
égoïste de la littérature comme ce qu'on
avait à faire à deux amoureux fou de la
littérature vous avez confronter vos
points de vue non c'est pas en tout cas
je vous remercie
messieurs et comme hier c'est un terme
de ces débats je vous demanderais de
vous serrer la main s'il vous plaît à
grand plaisir à bien
[Musique]
louis ferdinand céline est et médecins
son roman voyage au bout de la nuit paru
en 1932 est considéré comme un des
chefs-d'oeuvre de la littérature
française une vision désabusée plutôt
désespérée sur l'humanité après les
boucheries de la guerre de 14 18
patrick pelloux est médecin il est
médecin urgentiste et rappelez vous
c'est lui en août 2003 qui alerte la
france sur les dangers de la canicule
cette canicule tu feras près de 15000
morts des personnes âgées pour la
plupart patrick peloux continue son
travail de mise en garde contre les
risques sanitaires
il a publié urgentistes chez fayard
aujourd'hui et nous livre sa lecture du
roman de céline voyage au bout de la
nuit
louis ferdinand céline patrick peloux
deux médecins deux regards sur une
humanité souffrante qui ne sont pas ces
différentes qu'on pourrait l'imaginer
mais surtout écoutez bien vous allez
entendre la voix étrange de louis
ferdinand céline
[Musique]
j'aurais pu faire mon céline avec la
canicule enfer voyage au bout du soleil
[Musique]
non je ne trouverai charogne un bill
haas noir je te ferai dans l' émir deux
ans trou noir autonome de vaches dans
les transes peut prendre à du show tu
verras c'est une belle assistance
tu verras verts commente l'on danse au
grand cimetière des onze ans ce ne sera
pas facile
[Musique]
voyage au bout de la nuit ça reste à un
témoignage quasiment historique avec le
temps et ce bouquin qui est écrit juste
avant la seconde guerre finalement entre
les deux guerres ils sortent d'une
guerre ou eu un nombre de morts
incroyable et où ils vont rentrer dans
une autre ils le savent pas et ils sont
avec le même état de misère et lui il
fait ce qu'il peut et il fait tellement
ce qui peut que d'un coup y y renonce ce
qui n'a pas changé c'est l'homme
c'est-à-dire la condition humaine
ces lignes sur ce qu'il écrit on
s'aperçoit qu'à certains textes qui
pourraient être vraiment calqué sur les
personnes âgées à l'heure actuelle avec
la halle avec une déchéance totale avec
ddt des mouroirs est passé dans des
maisons de retraite des fois il ya un
aquarium on sait pas si c'est les
poissons qui regardent les personnes
âgées ou de création des rythmes et des
poissons pour le bébé grasset
autant de descentes cards off important
aux mâles fabricant ce que lol ben
bernanke fayoum maintenant la vision de
l'hôpital ça c'est très intéressant
comment céline le décrit parce que à
l'époque l'hôpital c'était vraiment le
enfin c'est c'était là le l'endroit on
mettait les pauvres c'était là où l'on
mettait toute la misère l'hôpital
laennec avait été construit pour mettre
les malades qui étaient issus de la
tuberculose
on y faisait rien n'y avait pas
d'antibiotiques qui avait rien donc
c'était vraiment des mouroirs en quelque
sorte
et c'était la honte d'aller à l'hôpital
ça existe encore ça ça existe encore et
les structures d'accueil notamment du
samu social
beaucoup ne veulent pas y aller l'année
dernière en période de grand froid vous
aviez jusqu'à 4000 places de libres mais
ils ne veulent pas y aller parce qu'il
se dit je veux pas aller dans les
centres d'hébergement parce que c'est un
roulement de pau je ne suis pas pauvre
[Musique]
c'est pas des nouvelles que dans crocs
côté pourri ce que dit céline
ce qu'il dit c'est que en effet les il
ya beaucoup de médecins c'est des gens
d'argent lui céline il se dit je vais
pas leur demander du fric parce qu'ils
en ont pas donc il est dans une danse
dans une ambiguïté comme ça bon nous on
le voit aux urgences ou coûte pas très
cher on fait pas de priver on ne demande
pas d'argent on soigne point barre
il y en a plein qui vont voir des grands
professeurs dans à qui seront payés en
liquide du som a su côtelettes chambre
et là ils sont crédibles dans son
bouquin elle va voir ils vont voir des
gens qu'on paye grassement qui ont une
apparence donc du coup c'est sérieux
c'est comme ça qu'à tomber me migan
laurent pêne tu veux voir ce jeu et
compile que je vais te revenir enfin de
bafou ya j'en exaltation au parvis mme
auprès du lit de la jeune fille prostrée
la malade à la derni pour voulu
l'examiner mais j'ai peur des tellement
de sens c'était une telle bulle
on ne pouvait rien voir de son vagin des
caillots ça faisait glouglou entre ses
jambes je remis le gros coton et
remontaient sa couverture simplement
bien ça la scène de l'avortement c'est
c'est une scène qu'on voyait encore il
ya quelques années les faiseuses d'anges
ça s'appelait c'était une véritable
boucherie
moi j'ai pas connu cette époque parce
que je suis un tout jeune docteur mais
quand on regarde dans la littérature
ça faisait plus de morts que de bien à
l'époque c'était un crime quasiment il y
avait des femmes qui finissait en prison
pour ça c'est une scène absolument
épouvantable parce que vous avez
l'hémorragie dit il décrit exactement
comme si on y était et en fait la suite
était pouvant table parce qu'elle meure
[Musique]
chacun possède ses raisons pour s'évader
de sa misère intime et chacun de nous
pour y parvenir emprunte aux
circonstances
quelques ingénieux chemin heureux ceux
auxquels le bordel suffit d'en c'est
marrant parce que c'est une belle
conclusion parce que heureux ceux
auxquels le bordel suffisent ça pourrait
être vraiment l'un des principes de des
services d'urgence
en fait merci parce que je vais y avait
longtemps que j'avais pas lieu voyage au
bout de la nuit
ça m'a fait du bien de relire ce clap
[Musique]
dans ses rangs ce python que je reçois
ce soir bernard werber pour le souffle
des dieux paru chez albin michel
depuis le succès considérable des
fourmis en 1991 bernard werber est un
des auteurs français les plus lus dans
le monde
c'est même une sorte de dieu vivant en
corée ce soir nous allons demander à
nous allons offrir l'occasion à bernard
werber de répondre à une critique celle
d'hubert artus de l'écho des savanes
bernard werber bonjour bonjour alors
avant de vous laisser en tête-à-tête
avec hubert artus connaissait le le
principe de notre séquence vous pouvez
intervenir et interrompre à tout moment
la chronique par londres de ce souffle
des dieux alors c'est le deuxième volet
d'un triptyque commencé en 2004 avec
nous les dieux à peu une méthode comment
devenir dieu une méthode accélérée
comment devenir dieu est là votre votre
héros michael pinson est passé en
deuxième année
après avoir eu à gérer des animaux il a
des hommes à gérer et sa formation va
être assurée par les douze yeux
du panthéon grec voilà et on va
s'apercevoir que ces dieux du panthéon
aux quelques travers humains et c'est là
que ça va un petit peu se corser vous
êtes d'accord avec cette présentation un
peu oui
bon alors on peut peut-être voir ce que
hubert artus
j'ai mon écoute vous appuyez sur un
bouton ici on a tout dit littérature qui
est pétri de bonnes idées
attention c'est pas uniquement avec des
bonnes idées qu'on fait de la bonne
littérature alors m'a déjà donc avoir
des bonnes idées ça ne fait pas mal
moi je trouve que la littérature manque
d'idées justement et c'est vrai que je
me donne beaucoup de mal pour essayer de
trouver des idées nouvelles
le plus beau compliment qu'on puisse
faire un auteur je crois c'est que vous
faites quelque chose de nouveau avec des
idées nouvelles
werber son qui sait écrire sans qu il
problème est-ce que c'est par humilité
ou par sagesse on sent qu'ils osent pas
enfants qui se met pas à fond dedans
alors du coup il met en scène mais il
écrit pas du coup ça va encore peu
d'épaisseur alors met en scène mais il
écrit pas je suis d'accord avec lui
c'est à dire que pour moi quand j'écris
j'ai un écran dans ma tête c'est du
cinéma
est ce que j'écris c'est la description
du film tous les matins de 8h à 12h30
j'allume mon cinéma intérieur je vois là
dans un truc en scop c'est bourré d'
aventure vous rédaction et je ne suis
pas là en train d'essayer de faire une
jolie phrase avec un mot compliqué pour
essayer d'avoir un prix littéraire
je suis là en train d'être dans le
souffle de l'histoire et franchement je
vous dirais le fait de faire joli c'est
vraiment tellement secondaire ce qui
m'importe c'est que en fait c'est
d'oublier l'écriture c'est à dire que
mon lecteur il se demande juste qu'est
ce qui va arriver aux héros qui ne se
disent pas hawx est bien écrit cet
auteur est vraiment doué nom keith à 10
[ __ ] à le héros comment il va s'en
sortir la deûle en compte qui est un peu
un roman d'action
c'est un roman d'action fut bien trop
peuplée bien trop saturé et comme
souvent tout ce qui est saturée en roman
tout mystère il ya plus de mystère
littéraire c'est trop c'est trop et on
atterrit sur un défaut chez bernard
werber qui reprend et s'il était fauché
une grande partie du thriller à l'anglo
saxonne trop facile et bien le scénario
est trop facile
si mario trop facile je ne mets quand
même au défi de savoir comment on va
terminer mon livre je conçois mes livres
un peu comme des tours de magie
certes je commence par la chute et après
tout est fait pour qu'on ne trouve pas
la chute
pour moi c'est la première politesse
envers le lecteur c'est lui donner envie
de tourner les pages et lui interdire de
comprendre la fin avant que j'ai lu le
livre dont il ya un petit jeu entre le
lecteur et l'auteur qui est est ce que
tu arriveras à comprendre quel est le
sens caché de tout ce que j'écris
du coup ils caressent le lecteur un peu
trop dans le sens du poil
alors ça j'assume la caresser un rêve
j'écris pour faire plaisir à mes
lecteurs
j'écris pas me faire plaisir à ma maman
j'écris pub pour impressionner les
critiques littéraires
j'écris pour que mes lecteurs et du
plaisir
pourquoi ce que vermeer mettons deux
personnages pour coiffe qui met tant
d'éléments et surtout pourquoi est ce
qu'il fait une saga des sacs donc
j'assume saga avec les réseaux sur tous
les réseaux
pourquoi ce que lui justement parce que
ça a été fait ne veux pas faire un tour
unique
s'il faut bien je fais pas un thème
unique parce que j'ai fait un monde que
je n'arrive pas épuiser un seul livre
donc y avoir nous les dieux le souffle
des dieux et les mystères des dieux
parce que l'univers tellement personnage
tellement de situations que je ne peux
pas le régler en 500 pages et son
scénario et son écriture et son propos
philosophiques et mine de rien je pense
vraiment qu'il gagnerait est comme ça a
déjà été fait en cycle pourquoi ne pas
le faire en volume unique et seul un
coup de chapeau ça c'est pas facile
et werber lui un monde il nous promène
plus ou moins dans le futur c'est un peu
fantasy mais ils nous prennent avec nous
créer un monde sans anti monde il nous
créer un livre sans anti libre on
l'avait déjà vu dans cette tour
précédent et par les vice-présidents
l'armée revers il nous créer des
personnages qui sont en quête de quelque
chose il nous parle de kate il nous
parle de paradis et nous parle de
mythologie mais entre les personnages et
les quêtes des personnages il n'y a pas
de ya pas de diable il ya donc du coup
là aussi le diable apparaît dans le
troisième volume mais sont bien les
choses ce garçon en fait le diable pour
un dieu c'est le pragmatisme c'est à
dire qu'à un moment tout mais dieu
gentils tous ceux qui ont voulu être des
dieux moreau avec des peuples
sympathique font que de la science et de
la santé avec des peuples exemple et
tous ceux qui ont choisi de faire des
peuples guerriers se retouve gagnant ce
qui peut sembler immoral ce qui peut
sembler si ça le diable c'est à dire que
pour pour les dieux face survivre leur
civilisation et se retrouve être obligés
d'être dur et pourtant le bernard werber
c'est quelqu'un que l'imagination
foisonnante c'est pas facile facile de
mettre en scène des dieux de donner
chair à des dieux en plus on sait que
les dieux grecs n'étaient pas des plus
gros ils toucheront trust a cop eu là
tout va ils avaient des comportements
traître est très ambigu dont bernard
werber ici ils s'en donnent à coeur joie
par exemple de ce que valoir votre
personnage à un moment il est bi
aphrodite qu'on pense y aller
les pandas pc une call-girl complètement
d'infos ici la dure ils sont comme tout
vrai qu'ils ont des problèmes de
voisinage en pleine guerre par exemple
un moment du livre on voit des dieux qui
entre autres par le hip hop et techno
d'un avis inverse des bons romans
l'action alors je suis d'accord avec
l'idée mais j'expliquais pourquoi j'ai
choisi la mythologie grecque
simplement parce que je vais dire qu'il
n'y a pas actuellement de fanatiques
religieux y donc on peut parler
normalement la mythologie grecque et ce
en effet ce sont des dieux humains parce
que il ya des phrases courtes donc ceci
correspond parfaitement à l'action c'est
très visuel en 500 pages c'est un peu
long mais ça au moins ça tient le coup
le problème de werber c'est qu'on a
vraiment l'impression qui sait comment
faire pour donner de l'épaisseur à son
écriture qui sait comment s'y prend mais
encore une fois il n'ose pas y aller
or il est inséré connu du public est
lassé de livres derrière lui voire osée
de faire la question c'est pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils n'osent pas encore le
faire parce que c'est pile poil pour sac
pour le moment werber c'est un peu trop
gjervan correct et c'est ce qui fait la
limite
le gamin vers berne alors je te dire
juste une chose c'est que juste après
avoir terminé souffre des dieux je ne
vais pas faire le mystère des dieux
parce que j'en ai un peu marche c'est un
monde énorme
les dieux ça sature oui et lège fait un
livre qui pour l'instant s'appelle la
petite fille aux miroirs et qui est un
livre ou une petite fille qui vit chez
les clochards et donc c'est peut-être
exactement le livre que lui en train de
demander mais j'ai déjà pratiquement
terminé c'est l'histoire d'une petite
fille qui essaie d'avertir le monde de
de sa déchéance milan ac les clochards
pour l'écouter et que le ch s'en fout de
la défense du monde je sais pas s'il
reste encore non je crois qu'il a il
atteint fini oui je trouve sur critique
très intéressant mais ce qu'il m'a dit
bon je savais déjà gfa découvert dans
l'aude mais ce qui m'a dit montre déjà
qu'il m'a lu et ça me fait quand même
plaisir d'être
lui est critique on oublie souvent mais
en fait on écrit pour être lu en tout
cas moi ça m'a fait énormément plaisir
puis bon comme vous l'avez dit à se
critiquer c'est au moins quelqu'un qui
vous avez lui qui en a parlé et qui vous
a donné l'occasion de découvrir non pas
vos livres qu'on connaît bien
mais bernard werber parlant de ses
livres et ça ça me fait très plaisir
non merci la nuit au soir
[Musique]
e
didier van cauwelaert nous parle de
marcel aymé didier van cauwelaert n'a
jamais voulu qu'une chose être écrivain
est ce que c'est de l'orgueil ou bien
est il tout simplement un rêveur en 1994
il obtiendra la consécration avec le
prix goncourt pour un aller simple
aujourd'hui didier van cauwelaert nous
propose clown et le christ à partir
d'une idée simple si le sens qui est sur
le suaire de turin ou sur la tunique
d'argenteuil est bien celui du christ
cela veut donc dire qu'on peut récupérer
l'adn est donc clos né le christ on voit
ici que didier van cauwelaert flirte
avec les rapports ambigus de la science
et du paranormal est ce que c'est ça qui
l'a décidé à nous parler de marcel aymé
qui lui même investi ce domaine là dans
la jument verte ou bien dans le passe
muraille
c'est ce que nous allons savoir
maintenant marcel aymé c'est avant tout
un observateur en observateur de ce qui
se passe dans la réalité de ce qui se
passe dans ses rêves de ce qui se passe
dans le choc entre ses rêves et la
réalité ses rêves impatience ses rêves
déçus et la réalité telle qu'elle est et
pour que la réalité pour lui faire
rendre gorge pour qu'enfin le monde
devienne plus respirable
il faut qu'un écrivain se jettent à
corps perdu dans cette réalité et la
transforme c'est ce qui va faire toute
sa vie je peux pas dire c'est à cause ou
grâce à marcel aymé que j'ai écrit
j'écrivais déjà lorsque je les
découverts et tout à coup je me suis dit
ce que je rêve de faire il l'a réussi
donc c'est possible
le passe muraille voilà 1972 l'édition
c'est là que je rencontre marcel aymé la
première phrase
elle explique tout la méthode marcel
mais c'est à dire rendre naturel quelque
chose d'impossible et faire travailler
un postulat fantastique jusqu'au moment
où devient une nouvelle réalité et
surtout au moment où la réalité reprend
le pas sur l'impossible sur le
paranormal et la nouvelle commence ainsi
il y avait à montmartre au troisième
étage du 75 bis de la rue d'orchamps un
excellent homme nommé du tilleul qui
possédait le don singulier de passer à
travers les murs sans en être incommodé
est ce un hasard si j'ai mis en exergue
de cette enquête que je publie
aujourd'hui qui n'est pas un roman c'est
pire c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui dans le
monde
si en effet le sang qui se trouvent sur
ces reliques attribue à jésus est bien
celui de jésus
des gens sont en train d'essayer de le
cloner et l'église a été la première à
essayer de discréditer ces trois
reliques on sait aujourd'hui qu'elles
sont authentiques ou du moins qu'on les
a rendus tél car il ya le même adn sur
ces reliques c'était le même homme le
carbone 14 a dette et ses reliques du
14e siècle du 6e et du cinquième
donc est ce un miracle s l'ubiquité
spatio temporelle de celui qu'on peut
appeler jésus ou est ce un complot
planétaire pour nous faire croire nous
faire croire quoi que jésus a existé
qu'il a été crucifié et qu'il sait
dématérialisée dans un drap de lin en y
laissant son image le problème c'est que
l'église n'a pas arrêté de mettre en
doute ces reliques et c'est pas un
hasard si j'ai mis une phrase de marcel
aymé en exergue de cette enquête
il disait l'église et sur terre pour
protéger l'homme de la parole divine et
le hasard a fait quand j'ai préparé
cette émission du moins quand j'ai
décidé de parler de marcel aymé ce qui
était un grand plaisir
j'ai recherché une photo que j'ai
retrouvé assez miraculeusement dans le
bazar qui m'entourent c'est une photo
qui a été prise dans le bureau de marcel
aymé j'ai pas connu il est mort j'avais
7 ans il y aurait pu m'attend mais bon
j'ai bien connu sa veuve c'est à cause
de marseille mais je suis allé vivre à
montmartre à côté de chez lui en fait et
et un jour elle m'a emmené dans
l'appartement et dans le bureau de
marcel aymé qui restait complètement à
l'identique et il écrivait c'est moi je
pourrais jamais faire ça il écrivit en
face de deux fauteuils vides comme un
médecin qui reçoit une fin qui attend
une consultation de fantômes si vous
voulez et je voudrais dire un dernier
mot sur l'homme marcel aymé c'est un
écrivain magnifique qui a fait passer
son temps à faire voler en éclats les
tabous de la morale sexuelle du
conformisme de la gauche de la droite de
l'anticléricalisme dudukalo cynisme et
puis et dans la vie ça a été un homme
d'un courage incroyable dont la
discrétion a fait qu'elle va pas
traverser forcément la chronique il a
été l'un des seuls sous l'occupation à
écrire des articles contre la
persécution des juifs contre la commune
la création du commissariat à la
question juive d'une telle violence
qu'on savait pas comment le censuré cet
homme qui était en plus il y avait la
réputation d'être plutôt de droite on
comprenait pas et les articles
paraissait c'était tellement énorme que
ça passait mais à la libération les gens
qui avait écrit dans la presse on tue
des soucis parce que c'était les
journées autorisées donc les journaux
quand même de collaboration et en fait
on le fait sur proches extraordinaire
parce que prendre la défense des juifs
c'était bien mais encore fallait-il que
ce soit dans des journaux qui ne
paraissait pas voilà qu'elle était
l'homme marcel aymé l'homme qui a écrit
ces choses magnifiques et
j'ai une pensée pour la personne qui a
pris cette photo ce type polaroïd
c'était la fille de marcel aymé
françoise arnaud qui et qui est morte
cette année marie antoinette sa veuve
est morte déjà il ya déjà longtemps mais
tous les enfants les autres enfants de
marcel aymé qui sont ses lecteurs ne
l'oublierons jamais continuerons à
chercher et à le garder dans ses merci
visé van gogh là il ya dans libertés
et besson
[Musique]
bret easton ellis est l'auteur adulé ou
détesté d'american psycho qui en 1991
l'a rendu riche beau et célèbre a fait
de lui pour tout une amérique une icône
rebelles très sexe drogue et rock'n'roll
îlots de passage à paris pour nous
parler de son dernier roman lunar park
paru chez robert laffont
une art parquet est un roman tu
commences sur le mode autobiographique
et un brin complaisant et englué dans le
dans le bonheur mais qui va bientôt
virer au pire des cauchemars
on peut retrouver cette veine dans
american psycho 1 et 2 qui paraît
aujourd'hui en dvd
en attendant dans le journal intime
qu'il nous propose on peut se demander
mais pourquoi bret easton ellis at il
les yeux rouges
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok
[Musique]
et
ok
[Musique]
non
six mois prochain
à
comme un hommage
[Musique]
france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sam
bravo et bien justement
[Musique]
oui
soit on vient
m
the girl can't stand the strong à
efforts en ce sens qu'elles s'apprécient
on a bradé
c
qui
c'est un sort
[Musique]
ciao
m
[Musique]
nan aurousseau bonsoir mais si on vous
situe d'abord vous êtes né en 51 à
montbard vous êtes un attitude paris
fils d'ouvrier si l'aînée d'une famille
de six enfants puis pas né à montmartre
en fait je suis né à juvisy j'ai passé
toute mon enfance à la porte de
montreuil donc j'ai fait parti des gangs
de jeunes à travers onze ans dans les
années 60 70
c'est ça ou allez pouvoir j'étais par
mois j'étais un délinquant déjà assez
sérieux c'est à dire que j'étais plutôt
dissimulé je me baladais pas sur la
place publique avec un blouson j'avais
une petite veste tout à fait ordinaire
avec un calibre à l'intérieur voilà non
plus après ça s'était mal terminée que
j'ai changé de vie et maintenant je suis
écrivain
voilà un cinéaste alors moi que vous
avez un film à l'affiché actuellement
alors où est ce qu'on peut vous voir
écouter me voir moi ça va être difficile
mais mon film idées au studio galande
tous les jeudis donc ça s'appelle
enquête à domicile c'est un polar donc
encore une fois bien sûr donc et en noir
et blanc je les tournées en dix jours
avec 15000 euros
j'ai mis dix ans de post prod 1 j'ai
vachement galéré mais bon à la copie 0
allé au studio galande tous les jeudis
donc vous pouvez aller le voir
alors ce soir nous sommes ensemble pour
ce bleu de chauffe
alors le titre qu'est ce que c'est que
blood shops et c'est la vie de travail
des chauffeurs à l'origine des
chauffeurs donc les types qui chauffait
les locomotives en maintenant les
chauffeurs on devrait plutôt les
appelait les chauffer parce qu'ils ont
la prime mais bon au départ c'est parce
qu'ils avaient très chaud et chargé les
machines avec du charbon quoi donc c'est
des bleus dit chauffeur de locomotive
voilà qu'on a utilisées dans les
chaufferies par la suite alors
l'histoire l'histoire de ceux de ce bleu
de chauffe
on peut dire que ces histoires donc de
mammouth tu veux faire la peau à son
patron dolto qu'une sorte de ripoux du
des travaux publics comme on en trouve
quelques heures pour trouver
voilà donc ça c'est le fil directeur et
il va se passer beaucoup de choses dans
ce livre parce que ce mammouth a quand
même un passé qui ressemble un peu il a
fait des bêtises
1 il a fait son petit tiers c'est chaque
dimanche au paint américain 11 45 au
lieu de faire
on se calme et puis un jour je vois là
avec sa pince adverse et voilà et ça
ressemble un petit peu à ce que mammuth
c'est vous dans sa quête quelque part
c'est en double mais j'ai anamorphosée
vous savez les romanciers il s'inspire
parfois du réel parfois pas ce sont des
histoires vraies toutes les histoires du
bâtiment sont vraies c'est à dire que
moi j'ai travaillé régulièrement dans le
bâtiment c'est à dire ou à travers je
fais des films aussi donc c'est très
difficile c'est des métiers qui sont
pénibles aussi le cinéma et la
littérature enfin la littérature qui
aurait plutôt je suis romancier moi je
raconte des histoires donc j'étais
obligé régulièrement de retourner
travailler dans le bâtiment
et puis j'ai recueilli comme ça un
nombre vraiment assez sérieuse
l'histoire que j'ai vécu que j'ai connus
qu'on m'a raconté ce qui est pas évident
pour un pour un roman je veux dire ah
c'est d'arriver à prendre des anecdotes
tels que toutes ces anecdotes et de les
insérer un à l'intérieur d'une trame de
suspense mais ça c'est à dire qu'il faut
arriver à faire une sorte de système
d'ondulations des anecdotes avec la
trappe de suspense ok légère qu'on sent
pas et pour pas qu'on l'attend à
tiennent le lecteur quand même en
haleine jusqu'au bout je pense que le
monde du travail à ces niveaux là où on
pousse les gens vraiment dans des formes
de dépression
les gens peuvent vraiment pété les
plombs et se retrouver avec un grave
problème névrotique quoi et donc j'ai
voulu que mon personnage poussé mon
personnage dans son rapprochement avec
aussi la réalité qui intervient qui est
sordide et notamment le bébé mans dans
le puits où on va rebondir plus
connaisseurs qui est la goutte qui fait
déborder le vase en russie on peut dire
en mai vous parler effectivement de
débordements névrotique on a
l'impression quand même que cet homme
est marqué par son passage en prison
oui j'ai voulu aussi ça j'ai voulu
signifier que
certaines comment je veux dire certains
systèmes d'incarcération peuvent rendre
fou ils peuvent pousser des gens à
devenir des fauves ou des fous et on a
on a pu constater que certains systèmes
d'isolation sensorielle notamment sur
les jeunes détenus
il ne restait que deux solutions soit le
suicide soit la folie et comme j'ai
connu ça personnellement je n'ai pas à
m'en cacher je pense que c'était bien
qu'il évoque alors moi j'ai de la chance
parce que j'ai un caractère vraiment en
béton armé en acier et tout je m'en suis
très très bien sorti ce jeu c'est pas un
peu grâce à beaucoup de choses me passe
à 1 d'éducateurs normalement que je vais
pas évoquer ici c'est pas le lieu
mais vraiment un éducateur à faire un
travail avec moi qui a été
extraordinaire pendant plusieurs années
et je m'en suis sorti bien et très bien
mais d'autres n'ont pas eu cette chance
cette rencontre est un peu d'après moi
soit se sont suicidés ou peuvent devenir
des psychopathes vraiment sévère mais à
cause des conditions d'incarcération et
d'isolation sensorielle notamment ce
livre qu'on a aujourd'hui
et quand même le produit d'un conte de
fée vous l'envoyer chez gallimard et
chez stock c'est jean marc robert et
vous recevez une réponse immédiate et
bien écoutez c'est simple je l'envoie le
6 juin donc je finis je termine et je
reçois une lettre à un télégramme enfin
bon moi j'ai des problèmes je suis dans
la campagne tout ça j'ai fait couper le
téléphone lors je reçois une lettre de
france télécom j mais qu'est ce que
c'est un pays dont les cuves
transtelecom gentil mari marcel et où le
facteur venir ont fait pas l'autruche
lille a tout ça on sait jamais alors
jouve la lettre et joie je viens de
commencer la lecture de votre manuscrit
du nom mais quel est le blaireau qui a
donné au monde un du ska france télécom
et puis je n'ai en fait c'était un
télégramme ne pas terminer encore rien
fait et que je viens de commencer la
lecture quoi
le 8 oui par exemple deux jours après un
coup de fouet quoi alors au départ j'ai
pas gruger dit non c'est un blaireau qui
est de france télécom qui me fait une
farce il ya quelqu'un qui a remis mon
ami ce qu'ils sont gourés la preste et
ou quoi puis pas du tout c'était jean
marc roberts et voilà c'est
enthousiasmant sur l'humanisme voie la
plus à revenir à quelque chose parce que
là on est devant une citation de marcel
aymé
c'est à l'autre pauvre où tout le monde
connaît qui est dans la traversée
parisse et gabin et dans votre livre
vous l'utilisez parce que vous montrer
quelque chose d'important qui fait que
ce n'est pas simplement un roman
policier c'est un roman noir que les
conditions de travail dans lequel on met
les ouvriers fait qu'ils se battent
entre eux et que on avoue ni dialysés
pas du tout la classe ouvrière c'est à
dire que moi j'ai connu le bâtiment très
jeune j'ai commencé à 14 ans dans le
bâtiment avec mon grand frère qui est
mort maintenant paix à son âme et donc à
l'époque on pouvait laisser nos outils
tranquille sans problème vraiment
vraiment pouvait laisser des chalumeaux
les pense tout ça on pouvait aller voir
un cours pouvaient aller manger on
laissait des outils comme ça on revenait
tout était là maintenant vous pouvez pu
laisser un escabeau pour lui enchaîné
avant d'aller boire un verre ou d'aller
pisser
moi j'ai laissé deux clés à molette il
ya quoi il ya un nom l'a15 minute g et
épicée je suis revenue il était bas et
quoi bon c'est dégueulasse parce que les
mecs ils envoient les tauliers envoie
l'équipe on y envoie tu te démerdes sur
place on prend un chalumeau ont 38 des
jeunes mâles et tipis des robes jupes
des robes voilà donc ces décès est
celle-là mais c'est non mais s'est
montré comment eva là on a parlé de
votre critique de la mondialisation des
conditions de travail actuelles comment
on peut faire avec les ce qui se passe
actuellement sur le marché du travail
avec la pression du chômage
comment on peut faire d'ouvriers des
[ __ ] de pauvres sens de marcel aymé
c'est-à-dire d'ouvriers qui vont avoir
comme premier ennemi les gens de leur
condition ce livre dont on aurait pu
considérer que peut-être il pouvait
avoir une fin heureuse
il y à un espèce d'échappée vers la
folie moi je dirais que plutôt mon
personnage reste sur un pont entre le
cerveau reptilien et le neocortex c'est
à dire qu'il reste dans le brouillard et
il faut je vais pas donner toutes les
clés d'une chance mais il ya un livre
secret dans mon livre c'est à dire que
un roman peut en cacher un autre
c'est à dire qu'il faudrait se demander
si mon personnage est vraiment bibans
dès le départ d'ali d'où ils parlent
oui je crois que vous vous avez conquis
les mots vous êtes maintenant
vous présentez vous êtes un écrivain ah
oui il ya trente ans de travail en moi
j'écris tous les jours depuis 30 ans
donc il faut pas croire que c'est pondu
par hasard il ya vraiment un immense
travail derrière moi je dis une chose un
romancier c'est 100% de transpiration et
1% d'inspiration surtout dans le polar
parce que il faut le petit pourcent en
plus qui fait que le lecteur court après
vous tout le temps en tout cas un
annonceur je voudrais au terme de cet
entretien vous faire un petit cadeau je
pense que voilà vous connaissez les
gentils jeu en version originale j'ai vu
souvent et puis j'ai jamais aux iem
lâche déjà écouté ce que c'est très
sympa en tout cas moi je suis très
heureux d'avoir pu vous rencontrer je
pense qu'on a on a découvert un homme
qu'on a découvert un écrivain est en
tout cas nous on est d'accord pour vour
est invité dès votre prochain roman le
prochain d'abord en fait revenir mais
assez bon enfant
[Musique]
odin vite quand je te vois comme ça ta
ferrer là ça veut dire que c'est fini
pour ce soir là pour ce soir est
terminée bon tu sais que c'était la
dernière émission de l'année à et quand
j'ai commencé cette édition j'étais
promis un trio amoureux
je t'ai parlé de leonora delphine et
roberte un peu mystérieux en fait c'est
trois livres leonora c'est léonora miano
pour ce roman l'intérieur de la nuit
un roman du martray sont très durs qui
se passe en afrique un peu sur tous les
maux qui frappent l'afrique actuellement
et delphine c'est delphine de vigan
un soir de décembre là on est dans une
atmosphère plus intimiste rapport d'un
homme entre sa passion et son devoir
un livre je trouve extrêmement élégant
de factures comme son auteur j'espère
que c'est un auteur pour qu'on recevra
dans une prochaine saison et robert va
te dire bah il est là voilà robert le
dictionnaire culturel en langue
française sous la direction de à l'arep
aux éditions le robert alors ça tout de
suite
sur la table de chevet
à parcourir comme ça ce sera un beau
cadeau pour les fêtes j'espère je vous
j'espère que tous ceux qui nous en
gardons pouvons passer eux aussi de
bonnes fêtes
en tout cas pour ce soir c'est terminé
merci bien
donc par
assez bonne santé
[Musique]
avec monsieur les passants